(audience applauding)
- Wow!
- How are you?
- Hello.
You look amazing.
- Oh, thank you.
- That song was beautiful.
Camilla, I'm such a fan of
Legoland, can I go with you?
- Oh, my God!
- Please.
- Yes.
- I really am a child,
Camilla, I love Legos.
- Me too, I just bought the
R2D2 and I'm struggling.
It's for like five to 10 year olds.
- Oh.
(audience laughing)
So I did Yoda, I've done Yoda.
- You've done Yoda?
- Yeah.
I bought it for my son,
but really I was doing it.
- Sure.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I don't have an excuse
to buy it for anyone else.
- I just own it.
- Yeah.
- Like it's fun and it
kind of is very calming
and therapeutic, I like
putting it together.
I heard though that you
were recently in Texas,
where I'm from.
- I was, I was in Texas.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Were you shooting there
or just having a good time?
- The Lone Star state.
I was there promoting this fabulous gin,
that is from Scotland.
- That's the right state
to do it, yeah, yeah.
- It is, they like gin down there.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- We were in Houston and
Austin, it was really hot.
- Yeah.
- And honestly,
the nicest people, the great
food and the food, great food.
- Yeah, but you have a new
gin, so let's talk about it.
- I do, I have this new gin,
it's called The Wild Scottish Gin,
it's called the Sassenach
Wild Scottish Gin.
All the botanicals are from
Scotland from where I'm from.
- Yeah.
- The southwest of Scotland.
We've got toasted oats,
blaeberries, rhubarb,
Scots pine, heather, it's
a really balanced gin.
So we've been touring all around the US
pouring people gin and tonics
and having a damn good time.
- Well, I don't wanna be left out,
so I had them pour us one.
(audience laughing)
So here you go.
- I hope you made these nice and strong.
- Yes, I did, well, if I
made it, it would've been,
but I guarantee you they
were looking out for mama
and it's not that strong.
(audience laughing)
- [Sam] We like to serve it
with a little bit of apple
in there.
- Ooh!
- 'Cause we have apples is
our main citrus. But cheers.
- [Kelly] Is it like crab apple?
- It is, yeah.
- Yeah.
I have crab apple trees,
I grow them at my ranch.
- You do?
- Yeah, yeah,.
- We used to pick them, we can't eat them,
'cause they're really sour.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But they're great for gin, obviously.
- Yeah, well, that's why
I'm growing them. (laughing)
- Cider?
- For gin.
Well, it is really good, by the way.
We saw this photo of Sam in New York,
that I really wanted to show everybody,
because I mean, are you trying to pick up
every woman in New
York, was that the goal?
(audience laughing)
Because I'm just saying,
like what do you keep in
the bag, what's in the bag?
- What's in the bag?
- It's like a really fancy fanny pack.
- Yeah.
- I like it, yeah.
- It's a bit like the Tardis,
I've got everything in there.
- Yeah, yes.
- I've got bottles of gin and-
(audience laughing)
- Oh, it's like Mary Poppins,
there's so much room?
- It keeps coming out, yeah.
No, I mean, what can you get
in your spor, that's a sporran.
Keep your mobile phone, your lip salve.
- Okay.
- Anything else,
crab apples maybe.
- Oh, crab apples,
there you go, but you
can't eat them, all right.
(audience applauding)
His new book is called
"Clanlands in New Zealand,"
it's out November 7th.
So I love that like you-
(audience cheering)
Get it out, get it out.
- What did you give these guys?
- Yeah, so we gave them your gin.
- Gin, yeah.
- Yes, we gave them your gin.
No, I love that you wrote a book
and you get to like go all
over New Zealand, right,
like for this book?
- Yeah, right, yeah.
I went to New Zealand,
traveled all over the islands
and it's kind of like Peter
Pan's world, honestly,
it's got alpine, it's got glaciers,
it's got amazing
mountains, fjords, jungle,
flightless birds, great white sharks.
- Yeah.
- There's so much to do there.
It really is an incredible place.
- It's beautiful, I remember
the first time I went there,
I was like, "Why do I not live here?"
- Right.
- Yeah.
- Parts of it remind me of Scotland,
it's got a real Scottish connection
and that's kind of the
reason I went there.
But it is mountainous,
it's an epic, epic country.
- And you are the person that goes,
I'm the person that goes to a place
and like enjoys the scenery
and you're a person that
adventures around, right?
You do all the things that might kill you?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, I dived with great white sharks,
I jumped off cliffs, obviously,
they invented bungee jumping
in New Zealand.
- They did?
I didn't know that.
- They invented zorbing.
If you don't know what that is-
- What is, what?
- It's a big ball,
that you climb inside and
then roll down a hill.
(audience laughing)
It sounds terrible, it's great
fun, if you feel the ball.
- It sounds like the worst ride at a fair
is what it sounds like.
- Yeah, it's pretty much.
You then can fill the ball
with water or gin maybe,
or whatever you want.
- Okay.
Now you've reeled me in, okay, all right.
Well, I heard that the
foreword is Peter Jackson.
That's amazing, "Lord of the Rings."
So did you meet while you were there?
- Sir Peter Jackson, no, we
didn't meet him unfortunately.
But you know, my co-star Graham,
he had worked on "The
Hobbit" many years ago.
I was possibly named after a hobbit,
my brother was named
after an elf in real life.
(audience laughing)
So I was like, "This is meant to be."
So we went to Weta, where they build
all of the animatronics
and the aesthetics.
- Yeah.
- And they actually made me up
to be a creature from "Lord of
the Rings" and "The Hobbit."
Unfortunately it wasn't
an elf, it was a dwarf.
I got to play Groin, Groin the dwarf.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And it was quite a transformation.
- I know, wait, I wanna see the picture,
'cause it is quite the transformation.
- There he is.
(audience laughing)
- Yes.
- He sweats a lot.
- That guy is not picking up
a lot of women in New York.
(Kelly laughing)
- Oh, I don't know.
- That guy, I mean, well,
maybe a particular kind.
- Yeah.
- I have to ask though,
I heard this story, I love Egypt,
I've actually been to to Cairo as well
and I heard you were
there shooting a movie
and you were on the top of a taxi.
- Yeah, I normally get-
- Pretending.
- You get in them, yes,
here's me on top of a taxi
pretending to be on a horse.
So I'm driving around Cairo
doing this independent movie
many, many years ago and I
had to do the horse acting.
- I feel like there's a lot of horses
maybe they could have gotten.
- Yeah.
- It was a very cheap movie.
- I was gonna say,
I was like, you're out-
- And I had to pay for
the ride at the end.
(audience laughing)
- Like the Uber?
Thank you, five stars. (laughing)
- Yeah.
- Oh, my God.
I just imagine like was
everyone watching you
like on top of a car?
What is this movie and can I find it?
- No.
- Like what is it?
- (gasps) Oh!
(audience laughing)
I have one of those.
- No, it's never.
- I have one of those too.
- No.
- So wait, you did theater
when you were young, right?
- I did.
- Did you know,
when you were very young
that you wanted to do acting
like on stage?
- I was definitely interested in it.
I didn't know I could do it,
I'm still not sure if I can.
No, but I did, I got into
acting through theater
and for many years
worked on stage in the UK
and toured a lot and one show I did,
I toured around Scotland and
it was a sort of small stage,
much like this but smaller
and I came on stage
and during the performance,
I fell through the stage,
'cause it was sort of a temporary one
and had to carry on like
it was part of the show.
So like yeah, I'm sort of
doing half a monologue,
like looking out at
the audience like this.
(audience laughing)
- And then you became
a hobbit, you were half-
- And then I was a hobbit.
- You're half of you, oh, my God,
you just kept going, you didn't climb out?
- My co-stars just started
laughing and didn't stop,
but we had to just pretend
it was all part of it, yeah.
- Oh, my God, I would, I'd laugh.
- [Sam] The challenge, yeah.
- Yeah, I'm like one of
those people that's on SNL,
that laughs in the
skits, that would be me.
- Right.
- I'm not an actor, so.
Well, we have a photo from
that time that I wanna show.
So wait, here we go.
- Oh.
- Look at you.
You look like a little wee boy.
- When I was young and
innocent, thank you.
(audience laughing)
I was 22 years old there.
- I love it.
- Ah.
- Oh my gosh, I heard that
we have something in common,
so I cannot stand helicopters,
I'm terrified of them.
- [Sam] Oh, God.
- You don't like them either, right?
- Right, listen, in New Zealand,
I had to go on a helicopter
ride, it sounds amazing.
We went up, flew up 7,000
feet up into Milford Sound
on top of a glacier in
the height of summer.
- Yeah.
- Talk about climate change.
Thankfully, there's still glaciers there.
- Yeah.
- And I was in a kilt,
riding in a helicopter with a
kilt on can be a bit drafty.
- Oh.
- I have to admit.
(audience laughing)
But I was standing on
a glacier in commando,
so I feel like it's a first, right.
- Commando! And I like how
you say glacier, I like that.
- Glacier.
- I have actually stood on it.
It was Portage Glacier in Alaska
and it is actually sad
because now I look back
and like how it looked
whenever I was there,
it's even gone down like
since I was there as well.
- That is sad.
- But it is.
I was terrified, I took
a helicopter up to it
and I was so terrified in the helicopter.
I was like, "Is this how I'm gonna go?"
- Yeah, I recently had to to come back
into New York via helicopter.
It was amazing flying into the city,
it's such an incredible city.
But the whole time I was
just staring at the captain,
'cause he kept looking down,
I'm like, "What's he looking
at? Is something broken?"
- [Kelly] Oh no.
- I was pretty freaked out, yeah.
- And if it is, I hope it's
not the thing at the top
holding it all together.